welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
put a smile on that face with the
release of the second trailer for Joker
now making its way online
it looks like the Clown Prince of Crime
is cracking a few jokes smacking up two
blokes and generally causing mischief
throughout the streets have got them in
this new teaser and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you miss from the trailer i'll also
be covering the reactions to the movie
from the toronto screening festival
which will be at the end of the video so
make sure you stick around I will be
discussing some of the plot leaks here
so there could potentially be some
spoilers and if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into the trailer
breakdown okay so I haven't actually
watched the trailer yet I did however
watch my old plot leak video and we're
just gonna see if it lines up here
because I have a feeling that it might
and but we'll just go through this
trailer shot-by-shot
and kind of break down what's happening
okay so there's Arthur Fleck and we were
told that he has severe mental health
issues and this is sort of gonna make
him have to see a therapist but he's
also a budding comedian that's really
trying to build his act however it's not
going down too well and in the leaks we
were told that after his set bombs he
goes completely viral and is sort of
made a laughing joke throughout the
United States yeah and then we can see
there that his comedies not really going
over too well with everyone you know
little kids loved it but not everyone
does and this sort of makes him you know
kind of questioned whether he's doing
the right thing
and now we can see the 70s Gotham and we
don't know the exact setting of the film
but it's rumored to be set between the
70s and 80s that we don't have a
specific date if you look to the
left-hand side there I think you can see
the garbage bags now according to the
pot leak there was a garbage strike in
Gotham that's basically meant that the
entire city is just full of trash and
it's dirty not only in this sort of
gangster and crime ridden sense but it's
also dirty physically and yeah it's just
not a nice place to live okay there so
that little switch there that he does
that's actually quite interesting and
because we were told that
psychologically one of his symptoms of
his mental health issues is that he
laughs when nervous and the fact that
he's walked out there and sort of is
laughing and then goes very very serious
I think that kind of cements that yeah
this is a psychological problem and one
that he's gonna have to try and overcome
in the film though as we know from the
Joker he probably won't and there's his
therapist kind of going over everything
with him yeah this is all sort of lining
up at the moment and yeah makes a lot of
sense
the same question again there we can see
the trash bags there yet this is really
cementing for me that this garbage
strike is going on and that Gotham is
just a dirty dirty town we can also see
from those scenes that no one really
respects Joker and apparently in the
plot leaked his I did mention earlier
but his comedy set bombs and this gets
him the attention of Murray Franklin who
basically takes him on his show and
breaks him down but you know Joker he's
not putting up for it and yeah things
don't go as well as Murray hopes
[Music]
[Music]
when I was a little boy okay so yeah
that definitely lines up with what's
been leaked so far and Murray pretty
much makes him a massive joke and he
feels really just you know downtrodden
he's trying to become a stand-up
comedian just like I was trying to
become a youtuber and you know we all
get angry when we don't achieve our
goals so I'm gonna start wearing white
paint and terrorizing the Internet but
yeah Murray is just sort of taking the
mick out of him a bit and apparently in
the leak he invites him on the show we
do know that that happens and we didn't
have the reason and confirmed but yeah
this lines it up for a lot for me and it
makes sense and I like that this is sort
of going viral but it's in the 70s so
it's not on the internet it's just on
television but everyone is laughing at
him
[Music]
again we can see the garbage there every
bin is piled high with it and yet this
garbage strike it's very much the only
thing I've talked about so far in the
trailer breakdown but you know Gotham is
a dirty place physically it's a bit
dirty like your Aunt Shirley
[Music]
and there is I think Thomas Wayne and we
did have that confirm that that is
Thomas Wayne and he is apparently
running for mayor and the word rumors
that in the film that Joker is basically
his mother used to work for the Wayne's
and she was obsessed with Thomas and
she's basically brought Arthur up his
whole life to believe that he's the
element they're sorry the illegitimate
child of Thomas Wayne and this is kind
of what sends him on a downward spiral
[Music]
[Music]
so there's a clown on the newspaper
there I didn't quite catch the headline
but it looked like this right okay so
there's a murderer going about dressed
as a clown
and now I don't know if Pennywise is
gonna sue for that but yeah that's
that's a nice little touch there and
that kind of lets you know that the
Joker is going out there and causing an
uprising
now the uprising is meant to be of the
poor against the rich because Gotham so
dirty and one of the reasons that Wayne
is apparently murdered and which
obviously causes the origin story of
Batman is because he's running for mayor
and he also represents the rich and this
kind of uprising goes against him
and you can see kind of the influence
that is causing on Gotham and everyone's
dressed as a clown now and this sub
becomes the face almost of like like
beef a vendetta when everyone wore the
Guy Fawkes mask this is sort of the
anonymous mask that allows you to
basically commit crimes and it's also
the reason that Batman needs to wear a
mask as well down the line because it's
masked villains fighting masked heroes
they don't want their identity known
publicly and it's sort of yeah that's a
really great shot I think again we can
see the clown's rising and it is very
reminiscent of an anonymous M sort of
protest and yet you get the feeling that
the joke is really making an impact here
he's pulled as well I don't think zzb 2
will be Harley Quinn em as that's
already getting played by Margot Robbie
but who knows but yeah he's got a
girlfriend by the looks of it and
there's Thomas Wayne so this might be
the scene where Arthur confronts Thomas
and sort of asks if he is his son and if
he you know if he is is an illegitimate
son and it doesn't seem like Thomas is
taking it too well because if he's
running for mayor this kind of scandal
could really stop his you know
progression to power and Thomas err
sorry Arthur is obviously laughing
nervously um and yet another great
little scene
just got socked out by his potential dad
damn
it wouldn't be the first time one of the
wines has punched the Joker in the face
either sorry that dog was there
and here you can see him kind of
blending in amongst these masks it
really is just an uprising year and yeah
this is a great way the for the Joker to
kind of operate that's obviously going
to be very reminiscent of The Dark
Knight strikes again in which the Joker
goes on a chat show and ends up killing
the chat show host Dave endocrine so
yeah I can see that kind of playing out
here
[Music]
the one it is sending the clown that
should've just sent in Boris Johnson err
now political that don't unsubscribe
please okay so that's the trailer out of
the way but what are people saying about
the film itself well the movie was
screened at the Toronto International
Film Festival and reactions to the film
have been extremely positive with some
critics even calling a cinematic
achievement Film Festival co-head
Cameron Bailey explained to the Toronto
Sun that after seeing it he realized
that it definitely deserved to be
presented at their ceremony when
speaking on the film he said the
following first of all it's terrific so
it should play on our largest stage but
it's a really original take on comic
book movies and on the Joker character
in particular it's not based on an
existing story it has one of the
greatest actors in modern cinema
back in Phoenix in the lead and Robert
De Niro is in it as well one of the best
actors that has ever lived but it has an
interesting tone and approach to it it's
set in the late 70s early 80s and it
feels like it was made then it's gritty
and it's look it has references to
Martin Scorsese's film making and it
feels like a cinematic achievement on a
high level although it's working with
very populist materials it has great
ambition that's why it's article this is
of course amazing news and it's made me
infinitely more excited to see the film
especially after seeing this new trailer
which makes it almost seem like it could
be up there with the likes of Logan and
darker comic book films I'm definitely
hyped for the movie and considering that
it's already getting early screening
shows that Warner Brothers and DC
definitely have a lot of faith in the
film and are confident that it will do
well hopefully this will be another huge
step in the right direction for DC who
slowly seemed to be picking up speed
with Wonder Woman Aquaman and Shazam all
been great movies this has the potential
to be one of the best comic book movies
of the air and I can't wait to see if it
delivers on it obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this news and the
trailer itself there's anything I missed
and make sure to leave it in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
new Breaking Bad movie El Camino which
would be linked at the end it covers
everything we know so far about
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books and you can follow me on
twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this well so just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of John wick 3 on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the Joker trail out in the comments
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on September the 10th and the
blue arrow be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]